Sarah with us in Houston Texas hi Sarah
how are you are you better than I
deserve what's up I want to know if you
had any tips to get my husband on board
I'm just a beginner listening to your
show and most of it is my dad and he is
like well you know I'm doing money some
help I need tips to get him on board
okay how long y'all been married five
years
what's your household income like 51,000
okay and how much debt do you have
thirty and alone jingtian car payments
credit cards mm-hmm okay all right and
so you said help me with this and he
said what most of the credit cards are
all mine the car is mine in a student
loan as much he doesn't have anything in
his name so he said that I need to say
yes he said once because yeah I need to
say because I'm the one that's creating
a bit mm-hmm
so should I just leave him alone and
focus on myself or was I just wanted
like a suggestion well I believe a
different thing about marriage than he
believes when you get married you say in
sickness and in health for richer for
poorer now I would agree with him that
if you're going to keep doing stupid
crap that he doesn't want to help you do
stupid crap right right I don't blame
him for that and you don't either but if
he gets if he gets cancer he's gonna
want you to take care of him right well
you got cancer of the wallet oh yeah in
sickness and in health for richer for
poorer
and so go to him again and and I don't
want you two to laugh when you do this I
don't
want you to giggle okay you met you did
a nervous laugh thing you were kind of
nervous and I understand I'm not picking
on you okay but I don't want you I don't
I don't want him to think you think this
is cute or you him to think you think
this is funny I want him to think that
you need his help and you say listen
you're better with money than I am and
I'm really sick of being like this and I
really need your help I really need you
to jump in here with me and let's do
this budget stuff together I want to not
ever be back in debt again I want to get
out of debt
and I need my husband to walk with me to
do that well what do you say if you said
that yeah the season he's not a bad guy
he's just like I don't want to keep
giving you money and I don't want to
bail you out if you're gonna keep doing
this crap that's what he's saying right
I don't want to be an enabler is what
he's saying but but if you just said hey
honey I need your help you know it's
like help me bring the groceries in from
the car you know help me put the dog out
you know help me by doing whatever this
I need your help and and you know he
loves his wife I love my wife my wife
says I need your help I'll help her but
now she starts you know wagging her
finger and starts telling me what to do
we might get a different reaction I
think that you know I think he'll help
you if he believes that this is like
something you're really serious about
and you're not scamming him and you're
not and you really want to change it Hey
after five years of marriage I want us
to have the rest of our lives debt-free
and you're really good at this you don't
have any dad and yet you've got me and I
got some so let help me get this cleaned
up so we can work together to really
have a cool future and I think he will
and I think the more he sees you guys
working together and winning with this
the more he'll pour even his income
combine your incomes which you should do
by the way should do you should combine
your incomes and but he's gonna be a
little hesitant to do that as part the
start of this and that's understandable
but I would you know I keep pushing on
him on this because it's very important
for y'all's relationship
that you love each other well in the
area of money with kindness and
gratitude and those kinds of things
needs to show up in your money towards
each other
generosity towards each other in your
money it's a good way to be married it's
a really good way to be married